[Musique]
faites attention sur la route c'est
glissant
puis vous viendrez chercher votre auto
demain vous êtes encore ici il reste
encore du monde
je croyais que c'était fini désirer en
même temps qu'à être ici j'adore les
grandes conversations alors en fin de
soirée après la fête
j'aimerais avoir une discussion sérieuse
parce que demain est un autre fait et on
va manquer de chocolat parce que la fête
demain il valoir
9 milliards de personnes 9 milliards de
personnes qui veulent tous leur part de
gâteau et c'est normal il faut se poser
la question comment est ce que je vais
préparer ça je vous présente bernard
bernard cesser le pâtissier celui qui
nous fait nous beau gâteau au chocolat
qui habite pas très loin il fournit le
quartier un four trois employés son
inventaire imaginez l'équipe bernard je
lui arrive de demain je ferai un party
de bureau un québec qui ont à peu près
600 employés puis là pour demain j'ai
besoin des gâteaux au chocolat pour 600
personnes
bernard c'est une personne c'est un
entrepreneur il connaît bien le business
qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'ils vont me
dire peut-être 300 gâteau au chocolat ou
un immense gâteau pour 600 personnes il
faut seulement dire je suis désolé louis
je peux peut-être fournir peut-être une
dizaine de gâteaux pour demain je
travaille fort on va faire du temps
supplémentaire mais mon four et pas
assez gros pour faire le méga gâteau
j'ai passé de farine j'ai passé neuf
j'ai passé le monde et j'ai pas assez de
chocolat voilà qu'est ce que je vais
faire j'ai besoin d'un gros gâteau pour
neuf milliards de personnes excusées
pour 600 personnes pour demain alors je
peux aller essayer de faire le tour des
pâtissiers où je peux le faire le tour
des autres planètes
on va aller chercher du chocolat je peux
accaparer tout le chocolat du monde
entier pour mag et si l'on se transpose
à un entrepreneur j'ai une entreprise on
a des ressources
on a un inventaire de matériel les
composantes électroniques des boîtiers
et cetera qu'on livre nos clients donc
bernard un peu comme moi on doit
comprendre quels ingrédients avons nous
besoin pour livrer la marchandise
donc notre gâteau au chocolat au point
de vue business ont dit ok j'ai besoin
de farine temps de farine
j'ai besoin d'eux peut-être pour neuf
milliards de personnes à peu près un
milliard de sacs de farine des oeufs du
sucre du lait du café je dois gérer un
inventaire si j'en achète trop je joue
est mal pris ça va nous coûter
énormément cher cysoing gens n'achètent
pas assez je suis incapable de
satisfaire nos clients en un problème
les neuf milliards de personnes c'est
nos clients qu'est ce qu'on va faire
pour les satisfaire
donc si on vient plus loin que c'est
quoi mon problème avec le chocolat de
chocolat il semble que plus savoir plus
en sommes il est temps que j'en mange
mes filles
halloween c'est quand j'étais jeune
quand j'étais jeune quand on avait une
tablette de chocolat c'est à la fête
c'est à la fête
mais le dernier arles wings étaient
sains tablettes de chocolat c'est rendu
que ses pulls à fait d'avoir du chocolat
et le chocolat evil 2 ou l'autre donc là
pour faire le meilleur gâteau pour neuf
milliards de personnes
j'ai besoin de beaucoup de chocolat
alors le chocolat vient de vous donc
bernard il peut se dire je vais appeler
mon distributeur j'ai besoin d'à peu
près 100 millions de kg de chocolat le
destructeur il voit une belle affaire ah
oui lequel je vais me renseigner à mes
fournisseurs qui sont les raffineurs de
chocolat à qui j'ai besoin de 100
millions de kg de chocolat à belles
opportunités d'affaires je vais aller
voir les fermiers qui font le cacao et
j'ai besoin de 100 milliards le kg de
graines de cacao mais vers qui vont-ils
se retourner en business ce qu'on oublie
souvent c'est que notre fournisseur
principal
si l'environnement on n'aime pas
entendre parler d'environnement on est
tannés d'entendre parler d'environnement
parce qu'on entend parler de plus en
plus et on va en entendre parler plus en
plus parce qu'on a un problème de
business
on a un problème d'affaires c'est les
ressources et ça nuit à la croissance
des entreprises c'est la disponibilité
de ressources
le chocolat le cacao vient des pays qui
ont acquis permettre cet agriculteur
l'heure au québec
pour l'instant c'est difficile d'avoir
du cacao peut-être qu'avec les
changements climatiques dans une dizaine
d'années on va pouvoir faire pousser du
cacao
on n'espère pas mais c'est une
possibilité
donc pour l'instant côte d'ivoire
indonésie et l'activité de déforestation
est phénoménal pour faire des
plantations de cacao
parce que le gâteau qu'il faut préparer
pour demain
il est immense et on se retourne tout
vers la mer nature le notaire pour nous
fournir ces ressources là on parle de
l'air qu'on respire au point de vue
business l'air que je respire c'est un
bien que je consomme je le paye pas
malheureusement parce qu'on ferait
peut-être un peu plus attention si le
paient la sela l'environnement qui nous
la fournit l'eau c'est l'environnement
qui nous le fournit le climat le climat
qu'est ce qu'on est prêt à payer pour
vivre dans un environnement qui est
entre 20 et 25 degrés plutôt que dans un
environnement qui est entre 50 et 60
degrés c'est une question d'affaires on
a besoin de ressources et notre
environnement nous font ni où nous
fournissait des ressources
suffisamment pour être capable d'y
arriver mais c'est clair que pour neuf
milliards de personnes le gâteau il va
être vraiment difficile à faire
la première chose en affaires comme pour
bernard il connaît son inventaire la
première chose qu'on doit faire pour
savoir est ce qu'on peut faire un gros
gâteau au chocolat s'y connaître
l'inventaire les moteurs et la base
toutes les décisions d'affaires si on
connaît pas notre inventaire on appelle
ça souvent à la tragédie du bien commun
allez allez allez on va tout prendre le
chocolat tout prendre le chocolat puis
les justes pour nous puis après on va
voir un problème de gestion de l'offre
et la demande parce qu'on n'aura plus de
matière pour répondre à la demande
demain la connaissance de l'inventaire
nous permettre d'optimiser nos processus
d'affaires optimiser notre capacité à
respirer de l'air pendant longtemps
parce que tout est un inventaire depuis
trente ans on s'évertue à développer des
technologies qui vont nous amener cet
inventaire les technologies elles
existent actuellement on utilise les
images satellites qui sont par dessus
l'indonésie côte d'ivoire on est capable
de détecter les activités de
déforestation pour voir jusqu'à quel
point on est en train d'utiliser les
ressources de la terre et aussi il n'y a
pas de mesurer les capacités de l'enfant
de la terre à nous fournir ces matières
là les technologies sont là
après on peut suivre précisément le
cacao
pour savoir où est ce qui semble s qui
est distribuée de façon équitable
est-ce que c'est des enfants qui en fait
poussé le cacao a plutôt qu'aller à
l'école c'est quoi la quantité d'eau
qu'il prenne etc
on n'était pas de mesure et maintenant
l'inventaire précisément puis ces
technologies ont été développées par des
personnes mais les technologies et ceux
qui ont l'espoir que les technologies
vont sauver l'humanité et régler le
problème de gestion d'inventaire
ils se trompent les technologies c'est
comme un livre le livre faut l'ouvrir
il faut lire il faut comprendre les
technologies qui amène le niveau
d'inventaire de notre environnement
le livre est là mais qui veulent
utiliser
c'est comme d'hab' tél notre compagnie
on a développé des technologies
mais les technologies sans nous sera
serait rien elle n'existerait pas le
nous qui nous définit qui sommes les
consommateurs qui sommes les
gestionnaires de cet inventaire non on
se sent actuellement déresponsabiliser
par rapport aux ressources
on a l'impression que c'est infini ou si
c'est fini on a l'âme zara déterminée
elle est où la limite de notre
consommation
mais c'est nous avec l'utilisation des
technologies qui nous amène des
informations qui allons pouvoir
contrôler notre niveau d'inventaire
la grande question est de savoir qui va
contrôler saint-hermentaire est ce que
quelqu'un déjà entendu parler la terre
d'hier comme bernard hayot je veux pas
te livrer ça à cause que la terre ne pas
de voix que nous entendons on pense que
tout est beau mais vous le savez très
bien
la petite voix intérieure de nous elle
nous dit que je devrais peut-être trouvé
une façon d'écouter la terre
mais sa petite voix elle a bien raison
et on vous amène maintenant les
technologies qui vont vous permettre
d'écouter cette voie là précisément mais
la question la plus importante c'est
qu'allez vous faire
qu'allons-nous faire avec cette
information est ce qu'on va laisser la
gestion de l'inventaire a mais à qui on
peut laisser la gestion de l'inventaire
domaine la misère lds que c'est une
personne est ce que c'est un
gouvernement ce que c'est une
corporation qui vous naissez de gestion
de l'inventaire
je crois pas je crois que nous sommes
responsables et nous avons l'obligation
de gérer un inventaire pour le futur
est ce nous l'avons est activé par la
première chose la plus importante ce qui
a fait qu'on a développé les
technologies pour amener cet inventaire
l'or devant le mans c'est la volonté
cette volonté-là fait des miracles
cette volonté-là cris des technologies
pour le bien de l'humanité
cette volonté là maintenant doit amener
l'utilisation de ces technologies là
pour le bien de l'humanité parce qu'une
technologie sans volonté c'est que les
pas de changement et on va aller vers un
mur de plus en plus rapidement
on est face à un choix
j'ai trois enfants un grand garçon deux
jeunes filles le gâteau pour peut-être
falloir leur pensée est ce qu on veut
tout s'approprier les biens puis fermé
les yeux sur qu'est ce qui va se passer
à l'extérieur de nos frontières
dans un monde global tel qu'il est je
crois pas que c'est une solution
réaliste
la solution c'est nous devons
s'approprier de l'inventaire de la
planète et le gérer nous mêmes en
considération des neuf milliards de
personnes
la part de gâteau va peut-être être plus
petit mais le parti doit être nettement
meilleur parce que hier soir
en fait la fête mais j'avoue que j'ai un
malaise
j'avoue que j'ai un malaise devant les
jeunes filles de dire on fait la fête
mais je sais que j'ai mal l'inventaire
alors nous avons le pouvoir maintenant
de pouvoir préparer une fête où on va
être absolument libre de cette intuition
qui est quelque chose qui marche pas
puis ça va être un vrai parti
imaginons ensemble qu'on fait une fête
où on a confiance que cette fête vous
pouvoir se perpétuer tout au 5 août et
aussi longtemps que la terre nous le
permet et qu'en plus on va être
confiants que nos petits enfants aussi
vont pouvoir continuer cette fête là
puis chocolat 9 milliards de personnes
peuvent en avoir mais peut-être pas à la
quantité
on prend actuel alors notre volonté et
notre curiosité vont nous amener à faire
ce pas merci
[Applaudissements]